ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد قال رئيس
الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان
لعشرات الالاف من انصاره في اول ظهور عام
له منذ اطلاق النار عليه في وقت سابق من
هذا الشهر انه سيلغي مسيرته الاحتجاجيه
الى اسلام اباد لانه يخشى من ان تتسبب في
احداث فوضى في البلاد موضحا انه سيقاتل
حتى اخر قطره دم كمال ونظم خان احتجاجات
في انحاء البلاد لضغط على الحكومه لاجراء
انتخابات مبكرا منذ الاطاحه به من السلطه
في امريكا وكانت الاحتجاجات ستصل الى
ذروتها بمسيره الى اسلام اباد مما هدد
بتفاقم الفوضى السياسيه
بان حزمه حركه الانصاف ان سحب من المجالس
الاقليميه والوطنيه في البلاد
وسيخرج من هذا النظام الفاسد وفق قوله
وكان حسبه قد استقال من البرلمان الوطني
بشكل جماعي في اب قبل التصويت على انتخاب
رئيس وزراء جديد الا ان معظم الاستقالات
لم يتم قبولها بعد
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اسلام
اباد الدكتور جاسم تقي بعد قليل سيكون
حاضر معنا رئيس معهد الباب الذي دراسات
الاستراتيجيه ومن اسلام اباد حاضر معنا
حذيفه فريد الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بك حذيفه سابدا معك حذيفه نتابع تصريحات
عمران خان رئيس الوزراء السابق متابع كذلك
تلويحه بن سحاب حزبه تلويحه بالشارع
فالسؤال المطروح هل ما زال لعمران خان عمر
سياسي حقيقه في الداخل
تحيات التي
الساده المشاهدين
طبعا عمران خاننا سوف يبقى لديه زخم في
شارع الباكستاني هذا كلام لا جدا فيه ولكن
حاليا في ظل الظروف الحاليه ودعوا اهل
المضاربه انتخابات مبكرا هذه فقط احلام
لحزب الانصاف واحلام لانصار حزب الانصاف
التصريحات عمران خان يوم امس في في
مظاهراته هي كانت فقط لحفظ ماء الوجه مثل
تصريحات التي اطلقها يوم الخامس والعشرين
من مايو في مظاهرته الفاشله في اسلام اباد
سابقا حين موعد بين سوف يعود خلال سته
ايام ان لم تقم الحكومه باجراء انتخابات
مبكرا لم يحصل ذلك وحتى وعده همم وتهديده
بان حزب الانصال سوف يستقيل من البرلمانات
وسوف يقوم بحل برلماني البنجاب وبرلمان
خيضر خام اليوم فؤاد جود للقياده في حزب
الانصاف قال لن نقوم بحل برلماني اقليم
كشمير واقليم تركستان بالنسبه للاقليم خير
الاقليم البنجاب
البنجاب ليس في يد عمران خان مباشره وان
مافيه حديثه الحليفه الغير مؤكد البته وهو
ترويز ترويز الهي من وصفه عمران خان سابقا
بانه اكبر سارقي البنجاب فقط عمران خان
لديه حزب او لديه عفوا اقليم خيبر خيبر
دكتور لو تكلمنا عن حل البرلمان
لما تقول بان همم
الذهاب الى الانتخابات مبكرا هذا ضرب من
الخيال تقول همم ولكن تسريبات تقول بانه
عمران خان ليس الوحيد الذي يطالب بذلك
هناك عدم رضا على الداخل السياسي
الباكستاني هل هذا الدقيق
لو تكلمنا ان هناك 14 حزبا يشكلون حكومه
حاليا في حاله ذهاب الى اي انتخابات مبكره
في هذه اللحظه هم يعتبر هذا بمثابه
الانتحار جميع هذه الاحزاب السياسيه
السؤال لما لانه في خلال ثمانيه اشهر
الماضيه لم تقدم هذه الاحزاب شيئا البته
بل اصبحت الاوضاع الاقتصاديه اكثر سوءا من
فتره عمران خان هم وعدوا بعد مجيئهم بان
لوضع سوف تتحسن فذهابهم الى او اعلانهم عن
الانتخابات مبكرا دون الوصول الى هذه
المرحله او على الاقل اعاده الامور الى ما
كانت عليه فتره عمران خان هذا بيحدد سوف
يكون بمثابه الضربه القاصمه اللي هي عودته
مره اخرى الى الى الحكم وتحديد الحزب
الرابطه بقياده الشهباء بقرار الشهباء
الشريف جميع الاحزاب الموجوده في الحكومه
الحاليه الاحزاب الاختلافيه والحكومه
الائتلافيه هم في حاجه وقت على الاقل
اعانه الامور الى ما كانت هذه ايام ايام
عمران خان حتى يصبح الجميع على مستوى واحد
امام الشعب الباكستاني في الانتخابات
حينما يتم الاعلان عنها طيب بيت ضيفنا من
اسلام اباده دكتور جاسم تقي جاهز معنا
دكتور جاسم اهلا بك معنا كنا نتحدث عن
مطالب وتصريحات في الواقع همم عمران خان
التي يريد منها طرح او الضغط للوصول الى
انتخابات مبكره ضيفي يرى بان هذا ضربا من
الخيال بانه عمرا خان له شعبيه ولكن لا
يمكن للاحزاب ان تنتحر همم بطريقه جماعيه
انصحها تعبير ما رايكم
نعم انا اتفق مع هذا
اعتقد يحلم لا زال يحلم حتى الان
لان
الوضع السياسي الداخلي في باكستان كله ضده
وان كان الناس معه ويؤيدونه بشكل كبير
ولكن المؤسسه العسكريه ينتقد
رئيس اركان الجيش الجديد
معروف عنه بانه
ايضا ضد لانه هو سبق وان عزله عمران خان
منصب رئيس المخابرات العسكريه همم
انشغل المنسف فقط لمده ثمانيه اشهر بينما
يعني همم القانون الباكستانيه يقول ان
الرئيس المخابرات العسكريه يبقى في مصر
لمده ثلاث سنوات
عمران يعني ايضا له مشكله مع جهاز
المخابرات العسكريه كلها
يعني حاول ان يكسب جنرالات الجيش ويقسم
الجنرالات ما بين مؤيد له وبين
مؤيد من الحكومه
[موسيقى]
فهذا من ناحيه الجيش امام من ناحيه النظام
السياسي في باكستان الاحزاب السياسيه كلها
مختلفه
يعني
الجميع جميع الاحزاب ضد شخص واحد
في كل تصريحاته تقريبا يتحدث عن الشارع
ويهدد بمسيرات اخرها كانت مسيره كبرى
باتجاه اسلام اباد هل يمكن ان ياتي تغيير
من الشارع ام يبقى هذا مستعد
الغي المسيره انه اسلم ما بعد على الرغم
من
العديد من الوجود وصلت الى مناطق مختلفه
قريبه من اسلام اباد وعشرات اليهود من
الناس يعني همم
الحزب ولكن عمران خان افاجئ الجميع عندما
الغى المسيره يوم امس فقال يعني الغاء
المسيره انه يريد ان
[موسيقى]
لا يعرض اسلام اباد العاصمه الباكستانيه
بالخطر
الاضطرابات
فيعني لا تعرفين يعني
من ناحيه هو يعبي الشاب الشارع او من
ناحيه اخرى ينقلب على نفسه ويلغي هذه
المسيره على الرغم من انها مسيره سلميه
والمسيره السلميه طبعا بيتدخل من محكمه
العدل العليا لان الحكومه اولا حاولت ان
تمنع المسيره لكن محكمه العدل العليا
تدخلت وقالت ان هذا حق الدستوري للمعارضه
وينبغي السماح لها همم بس شيرين
يتوقع بان اشياء يمكن ان يضغط الشارع ولكن
سيد حذيفه بكل هذا الكلام الذي كنا نسمعه
عمرا لم يعد له لا مساند في جهاز
المخابرات ولا في الجيش وحتى على الارض
يبدو الحضور محدود حتى وان كان كبير نبقى
دائما في الجانب السلمي همم من اين تاتي
ثقته في انه يمكن ان يعيد طرح نفسه كسياسي
قائد في باكستان
عمران
حذيفه ابقى معك
جميع الكروت الموجوده على الساحه السياسيه
لاي سياسي همم موجود نتكلم عن الكابتن
الديني لعب الكارت الديني نتكلم عن الكره
القدملي لاعب الكرت القبلي يتكلم عن الكرت
العاطفي والوطني لعب على هذا نتكلم على
كرت الخيانه والفساد لعب على هذه التي
تتكلم على كارت الايمان والتكفير لعب على
هذا الرجل لم يترك كارتا من الكروت الا
وقام باستعماله خلال الفتره الماضيه اخر
هذه الكروت هو هو الكابتن العاطفي بعد
محاوله الاغتيال الفاشله لعادل الحشود
ربما تخرج معه همم باعداد مهوله وهو ما لم
يحصل فقط هو توضيح للمشاهده الحشود التي
يراها مع عمران خان بامكان الجماعات
الدينيه في باكستان مثل هذه الحشود هذه
ليست افضليه لعمران خان فقط جميع الاحزاب
بامكانيه فعل هذا انت تكلمنا عن اغلاق
الطرق فرضا حركه او حزب تحريك لبيك يا
رسول الله قاموا بيغلاق الطرق في عام 2019
عام و18 عام 2020 حتى قام عمران خان بعمل
ضربه عسكريه ضدهم في لاهور العام الماضي
لتكلم نحن عن نتكلم عن رجل لعب بجميع
ويستخدم جميع الكروت انت استنفذ جميع
الكروت هذا الكرت الذي استخدمه يوم امس
وهو التلويح بورقه الاستقاله وحل البرلمان
كان بامكانه استعمال هذا الكرت منذ ان تم
عسله من المنصب لكنه لم يفعل هذا هو اليوم
يلوح بهذا الكرت بعد ان قال سوف نقوم بحل
البرلمان قال بعد التشاور اذا فرمته تهدد
انا حينما نقول في بدايه الحديث ان هذا
فقط كان حفظ ماء الوجه هؤلاء المتظاهرين
الذين اتوا بالالوف وعشرات لنقل انهم مئات
الالوف بحسب تعبير حسب الانصاف وانصار حزب
الانصاف مئات الالوف التي حضرت هل يكون
جزائها بعد هذه التعبئه الكامله والحديث
انا سوف نذهب الى السنه بعد ولا نعود الا
بالاعلان عن الانتخابات مبكر هل يكون
جزائها ان تقوم القياده القياده التي
تتحدث باسمهم فرض ان نتكلم عن حزب الانصاف
في قول بل اننا نعود الى بيوتنا وفقد نفكر
في نتشاور في حل في حل برلمان عمران عمران
خان حاليا ليس لديه كروت اخرى يمكن له
لعبه على الساحه السياسيه امامه الان فقط
حلوه واحد وهو لم يصادر اتفضل باختصار
الحل الاخير نعم ان ان يصمت حاليا ان
ينتظر حتى موعد الاعلان عن الانتخابات
القادمه في شهر اغسطس هذه الفتره يستغله
في في اكمال الحشد الشعبي له حتى يقوم
باستغلالها هؤلاء في الانتخابات القادمه
بدل من هذه المسيرات والمسيرات التي فقط
تضره لا تصب في صالحه في كل الحالات
تتماما التوقيت الخاص بهذه الحلقه كنت اود
سماع حظرتك دكتور جاسم فما تخص هذه النقطه
والحلول المتبقيه لعمران خان ولكن ربما
كشف في حلقات اخرى او شكرا لكم جزيلا شكرا
فريده الكاتب والمحل الاساسي والدكتور
جاسم تقرير ثم احد الباب للدراسات شكرا
لكم
ولا النقاش دائما بقيه السلام عليكم